encore été sur tf1 en 2007 j'avais loué
un gros bateaux un bateau de 43 m quant
à mon staff aulas les bêtes construit
mais j'avais omis un petit détail c'est
que un bateau à essence on met des sens
à liliane tyan tient donc au bout d'une
semaine on m'a dit faut faire le plein
moi le plein c'est le plein c'est comme
une bagnole combien ils étaient vingt
balles mais jake one un bal non mais ne
t'empêchera jeudi à bilbao mon sort j'ai
mis le truc là dans le réservoir et ça
donc diminue de 20 minutes 1h 2h 3h 3h30
pour m trente cinq mille litres de super
et donc l'addition était à la hauteur de
combat 75000 bull 75 nommé monsieur
connaisseur des lieux
j'ai fait une fois le plein est prêt je
n'ai plus jamais bougé du port
est resté à quai au port on ne va nulle
part où yayale ahmed prenait la lex
avaler faire un tour en lms plus jamais
ça pousse et c'est une horreur une
horreur et ben bravo bas castany c'est
toujours autour de l'argent mais écoutez
ma wii cccc mon karma de l'argent peu
d'argent de l'argent moins d'argent plus
d'argent voilà voilà j'aime bien c'est
trop d'argent la rivalité choquant qu'il
en a quoi tomber
la fopac faut patienter un peu ça y est
là et vous avez peut-être faire des des
prime 26g une blague à faire à lire un
jet privé de la toque à la
jambe droite qu'est-ce que vous êtes
beaux
jours qu'est-ce que vous êtes menteur
label aimez vous êtes vraiment
abaisserait net vous êtes encore plus
beau que flou
parce que là je vous vois flou et
j'avais moi refoulé
alors moi c'était je suis parti en
vacances avec une amie et son aile et m
elle était ma qué et son et son amoureux
made me dit en partant je te la confie
pas de bêtises les filles je compte sur
vous et donc partait quinze jours on
part tout les deux tout va très bien
sauf qu'au bout de 4 5 jours elle tombe
sur en gros un type comme vous
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'a et l'autre par des
autobus en deux temps quelle horreur
est-ce que c'était le mec charmeur
charmant
et riche et même parfois ça vous risquez
un coup de coeur incroyable et moi je
sais pas comment faire mais elle y va on
y va et moi j'ai un son copain au
téléphone et de jeudi que tout va bien
qu'on s'éclate il arrive jamais à l'aja
la voir sauf que justement deux trois
jours après qui débarque en surprises
non le copain et donc il a fallu que
pendant les dix jours qui restait je
jongle mois quand elle était avec
l'amant que j'occupe le manger pour 10
pour dire comment les parents se faire
du shopping et quand elle était avec son
mec dire à l'abandon elle est belle a
préféré faire du shopping une visite
guidée et c'est donc j'ai passé dix
jours à jouer c'était l'enfer écoutez
voilà c'est une bonne copie non pas ou
si
vous avez déjà vous aviez tromper jour
votre trou marié l'époque non chez me
suis aperçu qu'en qu'il est mort que
c'était l'homme de ma vie
non s'est jamais trompé fait que j'ai
j'ai eu déjà envie bien entendre m'a
toujours dit crétins une bonne femme
faut la choisir benmosche font la guerre
depuis longtemps voilà c'est ça quand
même c'est une des bonnes techniquement
c'est ce que je suis en train de
chercher
leur nourriture ton oui alors moi quand
j'étais ado j'étais en vacances avec une
fille ce qui me plaisait en fait dans le
village où on était il un glacier qui
organisait le concours du plus gros
mangeur de glace
on sort de buluwo jour de glace
pour l'impressionner j'ai mangé 19 boule
de glace donc génère fier de moi sauf
que plus tard dans la soirée je lui ai
vomi dessus
des succès vos soirées ben c'est pas
très tendance et a promis toute la bien
vos meilleurs mais j'étais en classe
c'est à vomir
mais c'est toujours dans la bonne humeur
et la banda oui j'aurais dû gagner
j'étais en tunisie vous connaissez tu
peux j'étais à djerba exactement je
connais très bien tu étais à djerba la
douce djaballah fidèle parmi les fidèles
des fidèles
et seedorf 180 g 8 ans chez avec ma
maman en vacances et on est dans une
sorte de réfectoire dans un club
vacances et je gigote beaucoup je bouge
comme ça et visiblement j'agace la dame
qui est derrière moi ce que je suis
insupportable et ma mère vidéo géraldine
ces bons lève-toi et vient côté de moi
et c'est deux hommes avaient pris des
bananes flambées et donc on lui sert ses
bananes flambées il ya un appel d'air
dans le réfectoire et elle prend feu
dire qu'elle rend oui mais c'est pas
drôle à
la banane la dame ana da la banane aussi
mais la dame
veut la paix par
de la chaîne en fait je me serais enfin
je me serais mise en torche parce qu'en
fait elle a pris le feu elle elle a été
rapatriée très très vite à tunis et
depuis je ne peux plus supporter des
banales formé il ya quelque chose qui
flambent dans un restaurant je me lève
je sors j'ai un malaise vagal alors
j'espère que ce n'est pas vous verrez
jamais tout de
la banale tomber le milieu droit
est-ce que vous avez la phobie de
quelque chose vous des bonnes ans mais
j'ai la phobie moins de 2 quad ou que je
pourrais avoir la phobie
pas bien bien voilà bien une phobie vers
la montée de huy
donc allez remarquer entre
[Applaudissements]
pas comment ça n'est pas très drôle
alors c'est quoi les trois là on s'en
fout j'y verrai si bernès j'aime bien
aller en vacances dans les pays de l'est
[Rires]
ça redémarre bien j'étais en vacances à
moscou c'est une bonne amie j'avais pris
un petit hôtel comment il s'appelait
céline encore il ya quelques années
s'est félicité vote 9 non c'était une
bonne amie que j'allais vraiment pas
m'installer là-bas non non ne crions pas
de polémique là oh la la la la la
et donc j'ai tiré ma meuf non non non
c'était un homme j'aurais bien aimé mais
ça c'est parfait j'étais aux armes
citoyens tu peux la france convient
pascal
garret une petite fuite d'eau comme on a
souvent dans les hôtels voilà donc je
mets un petit verre l'eau était un peu
rance ça tombait tout sa première nuit
bon deuxième nuit la fuite s'accentue je
mets une marmite comme on met souvent
dans les hôtels je mens la récéption qui
m'a remis la clé de
jeu mais la marmite mais ça s'accentue
book ou the descent la réception coeur
de la nuit jeudi à la dame madame buffet
fuite comme ça on pouvait faire quelque
chose aux auteurs elle comprend rien et
tout ça le troisième jour inondations
total dans la chambre inondations je
monte au dessus je vois un gain
l'étranger comme moi il me dit oilers
telle auto lock en fait j'ai reçu de la
piste sur la tête
directement dans ma chambre
c'est pour chaque d'appui via les
chemises jaunes
est mêlé à cette histoire et drôle où
les cours à l'hôtellerie oui tous leurs
italie canada alors petites vacances
petit anecdote ça lui est arrivé cet été
j'avais pas de casquette pour mettre sur
la tête et vous savez que j'ai horreur
de l'eau sur la tête tant que j'avais
mis toute une série de petites épingles
et elle était brillante et quand je suis
rentré dans l'eau non je pense qu'on
finir et quand je rentrais dans l'au
delà une moitié vue qui a été attirée
par le truc là qu'est exposée sur ma
tête en deuxième et elles se sont
battues sur ma tête exemple
[Applaudissements]
d'hystérie une b - mais je vous jure que
sais je sais je connais très bien des
cas qu'à des mouettes à céder petit caca
et là on a vu elle a eu une diarrhée non
récemment vacances hors
tension l'attaqué quelqu'un kahn y est
c'est la mosquée chanonat seul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]